do you ever get lonely  oh yeah for sure  um like a chess player's life is by  definition pretty lonely  um because you have nobody else to blame  but yourself when you lose or you don't  achieve the results that you want to  achieve  it's difficult for you to find  comfort elsewhere it's it's in your own  mind yeah it's you versus yourself  really yeah really  but it's uh you know it's um it's part  of the profession but i think  any  like sport or activity where it's  where it's just you  and your own mind is just by definition  only are you worried that it destroys  you  oh not at all as long as i'm aware of it  then it's fine and uh  i don't think  the inherent loneliness of my profession  really  affects the rest of my life in in a  major way  you